my fellow americans
the war in afghanistan is now over
joe biden brought an end to america's
involvement in its longest war
20 years which stole lives cost money
and damaged america's image in the world
a war to remove the taliban which again
sits in power in kabul
we're left with a simple decision either
follow through on the commit made by the
last administration and leave
afghanistan
or
say we weren't leaving and commit
another tens of thousands more troops
going back to war
that was the choice the real choice
between leaving or escalating
he promised all americans who wanted to
leave would be evacuated before the u.s
military left
they weren't somewhere between one and
200 are still there stranded but biden
insists not forgotten and for those
remaining americans
there is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
but the president faces growing
criticism from political opponents and
even those on his own side they say he
failed his leadership failed america
failed
the lies have got to stop the
accountability needs to be there but
most importantly americans need to be
able to be brought home this cannot be
our history this cannot be where this
ends
we will not allow it
biden insists he did the best job
possible after the previous
administration never mentioning trump by
name signed a deal to pull troops out
without political assurances
and to the new threat the group behind
last week's suicide attack at the
international airport there was this
warning and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
the airlift organized and carried out in
such a short space of time was
undoubtedly a military diplomatic and
humanitarian success but with americans
left behind it counts for very little
america has questions to ask about its
involvement in afghanistan questions
that are obvious and difficult joe biden
has been politically damaged by what has
happened over the last few weeks he
didn't start the war but what happened
at the end will hang over the remainder
of his time in office
alan fisher al jazeera at the white
house